or how about Jim Carrey for the grit oh
you were 12 hours I was in have to give
that three a.m. did you sign on MADtv
and I was going crazy not month-to-month
yeah I only did it for like I would do
it for a week at a time and you get
there at 5:00 in the morning and they
paint your face and put plastic you go
crazy they said yeah crazily coach yeah
who talked them into going somewhere
else because they would just sit there
uncomfortable it's so uncomfortable it's
so crazy that you just said that did you
see the post of him on Instagram no I
just saw it yesterday where they asked
him about the Grinch how kids come up to
him like like this is an old interview
yeah and they're asking him how he got
into the character uh and he morphed his
face with no make up into the brought up
you pull it up and I'm not even joking
yeah that was him right there I saw it
right no no that that's it that's it
that's it watch this
it's unbelievable another parent says
you know that is that's the Grinch and I
go oh [ __ ] that's all my must find a
wave to stop Christmas from Gaby you
know and rawls God dude was that not the
let me I didn't let me see that yeah
watch it again that's without makeup
he doesn't need Magus you know who look
at this that's the Grinch and I go I
must find a wave to stop Christmas from
God we know bro I'm taking the God
exactly that's an athlete that's a
nailing a wrestling tussle this weekend
with a guy who's fairly large but
compared to you everybody feels
manageable who is this compared to you
everybody feels well I need you don't
know Susie what's he do I just was a
jujitsu guy know he's easy easy
he's my comic comic but but he's a
college ballplayer
six-five Tom yeah yeah Kevin Mack great
guy and kmac is is a is a an athlete
everything he [ __ ] I would not want to
tussle um he's much bigger than I am a
speech aesthetic guy but I'm saying that
we were joking around and just to feel a
guy like that is is the difference
between you and everybody else is at
least I'm not with a
polar bear they sent out with a [ __ ]
polar bear came back and you guys
started wrestling you grabbed man
where'd you guys wrestle at Luke's yes
Luke tried to jump in and I [ __ ]
kicked his leg out music I wrestled my
deaf backflip
you're just wrestling around just a
couple guys doing some light wrestling
doing some light lubed up and did some
light wrestling Rathlin you guys want a
wrestle hey guys what do you you want to
do want to do some wrestling well I was
full of opinions you should have seen me
at Luke's guys next to me asked me
questions about the John Jones fight and
I'm going like this watch test probably
do what you did just start he's dipping
he might get kicked I don't want a dip
it's not that he's getting he's figuring
out his patterns makes Papa sick yeah
but I know my shed dude you know what
the best everyone knows me so when we
watch the fights in the green room
everybody's cool that made sure then I'm
going like this watch this now Sierra's
win in that corner there guys hey foot
on the outside I go look you wanna have
your foot on that look goes like this I
mean not always once again not always
hoof dicey yeah I say Luke a girl why is
he not throwing punches Luke OHS it's a
fight you don't know what's going on
maybe you hurt his hand like this
classic fight won stuff he's like you
don't know he's just maybe hurt his hand
there's a thousand things that's why
they unless you've been in there you
don't know everything in life I love
everything in life forget fighting is
details if you haven't done it you're
not gonna understand the details you
know I understand the nuances the little
as you get older you start to realize
things are way more complicated when it
gets awkward yes football soccer time
what happens to football and kids is
that changing already
no I think that I think the
participations down a little bit but hey
I don't think you're not the end of the
day and I hope also a great sport yeah
it's American sports you know so a great
sport yeah I do I think some people
watch the Super Bowl some mm-hm would
say 44 million yeah but also
mmm case for Boston 2 and 10 yeah that's
way back yeah maybe down a little bit
cuz parents are worried about it but
even the more the more research we get
with CT it's like yeah we
for posterity now they have the XFL
tried watching I just can't the XF oh
I'm okay with a break yet XFL is there
uh yeah no I I'm gonna see my the big
boys I've really enjoyed watching the
Superbowl on a massive screen that was
that clear you can just see every little
detail it's better than being man
yeah book being there [ __ ] being Mary's
right doctor hustle yeah
it's a I think I might go to the
Adesanya fight the oral mouth you know
it's really old
Romero's last chance at a championship
and I believe you're gonna see you al
Romero use all his wrestling and just
put it in go for broke that it's in an
eight I thought it was in April for some
reason I think it is April you're
sometime on March seventh a lot soon
yeah Hanako is it in Vegas yeah
do you mobile arena yep that's Vegas
good card every time it goes to a draw
yeah I mean or if it's a close fight you
all loses they just he just loses the
most part I haven't my autumn Adam
winning that last but um
Whittaker fight and that's all to the
yet they still got Whitaker pence verse
you could see the same way me saying
Whaley the the Beast oh yeah you go on
your nice you wanna understand so the
main card yeah I agree
this guy's killing me right now yeah
Edmonds a monster which guy Edna Shabazz
Ian Shabazz Ian
he's like the next big thing in the
middle way dude I don't know he's a
[ __ ] sniper yeah is it worse a
problem obviously for outdoor sniper
trains with Rhonda's old watch
oh he's a sniper he's a [ __ ] beast
really yes I'm 70 yeah you know I think
70 hmm he's such a beast yeah the carts
pretty good
you'd go to seed it's always better on
TV men I open for Cedric the Entertainer
nod what and this was like this was like
15 years ago and I had my son I remember
the Indian Reservation wouldn't let my
son on its septic it was like just that
a mom and like just let him it cuz they
were like strict can't have kids on the
property yeah cuz that a baby it's
casino and I'm just paying I had nowhere
to go like oh I got my kid you know I
mean so uh he get somehow he gets him to
come in lets him in and and I go up and
I do my [ __ ] I do my Tonight Show set
bro I'm doing all those [ __ ] bangers
just bah-bah-bah like 15 jokes compact
into like what we I think he gave me
like 10 minutes yeah I caught them all
in there man just bangers banners good
night Bob
3000 people they're jumping up I'm
walking on stage in my head I'm like you
know gonna fall yeah good luck bro yeah
no I'm being serious yeah you know yeah
[ __ ] and I look to my left and Cedric's
got his goddamn fedora on matching
outfit you know me and he's bouncing
he's looking he's like that's rump talk
about Jo koy make me work for that
[ __ ] money tonight let's go and he
shook my hand and walked past me and I'm
like oh [ __ ] cuz I woulda never said I
would have been like [ __ ] this show yeah
it was done I swear to God and to always
be my love always been my philosophy and
every time I hear about a comic who has
like some shitty comic I'm like that
guys [ __ ] doesn't have any confidence
yeah what is it
you're a [ __ ] through those softball
lob what you don't even hear about
people have a shitty comics for Oakland
yeah you do know you got it you if you
don't and it's not fair to your audience
either like you're gonna charge give
them a good show you got to show them
like one you're the headliner so like
you make sure that whoever's in front of
you crushes and then you show everybody
what a headliner does I've always said
that 20% of the audience if 20% of your
on saying the feature should have been
the headliner you're doing your job like
that's a great show
yeah I mean I remember Mike Young none
of them say that for me
I don't 100% you are the headliner
yeah I'm making a point I'll have
someone open like they'll say that I'll
make a plan I know I know but I'm just
saying like for me no they usually go
holy [ __ ] did even was there anybody
else on this like anybody lately forgot
me that said I heard the story about
Cedric the Entertainer when they did
that the Kings of Comedy Tour yeah so a
Cedric Steve Harvey by the way your this
is crazy are we on the same wavelength
right now like I'm not even joking with
you because the Jim Carrey reference I
literally just saw that yesterday's a
grudge thing and then this Kings at
comedy
you can look at my Netflix queue I just
watched it the other day two days ago in
my line Yoda you had two days ago we
watching he's never seen it before and
and I was just like oh my god I could
not believe Steve was the [ __ ] host
if it did you but that wasn't [ __ ] he
blew the deal went up and [ __ ] first
it birdie but you know Bernie Mac at the
time he was gonna like host you have to
open her yeah they did one show and they
were like I was like oh [ __ ] yeah you
need to be like what do they do so DL
Hughley wasn't in the originals there
was another guy and when they went
somewhere the guy complained he didn't
have as I forget who it is the people
find out really so they had three limos
and he didn't have his own he looks at
Steve Harvey who organized everything
and he was like yo man where the [ __ ]
my car see what excuse me is where the
[ __ ] my car yes cool story dude they
did that show they kicked him off which
guys I brought in Bernie where who is it
who God well I don't know the comic but
they but they kicked because he's
urinating me but the first night Bernie
goes nominate and crush like harder than
all of them they were they all had in
the in the locker room that night we're
like so Bernie's in girl ass from now on
and everyone's like yeah yeah and of
course Cedric no PL Harvey on the height
of the the chitlin circuit like like Ron
no one knew who the [ __ ] Bernie was this
guy was doing stuff he wasn't even doing
improv this dude was literally doing the
underground circuit yeah so for him to
come out swing like that it's just
[ __ ] my favorite part of that whole
thing is I like the mini docks that they
put them on we need jack
and and the one with Bernie when he
literally looked at the camera goes it's
my turn [ __ ] they already got
shows onions show yeah give me a [ __ ]
show while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gift it's a gift it's a gift